un invité de marque pour la mission
reconstruction de la droite laurent
wauquiez président du parti les
républicains un déplacement à l'école
idec d'aubergenville des formations dans
l'industrie et des rencontres avec des
étudiants et des personnes en
réinsertion professionnelle là j'ai
changé quelqu'un qui était au rsa qui
avait repris une formation pour ensuite
déboucher vers un emploi à la fin il me
dit le problème c'est que la différence
entre ce que je gagne en travaillant et
ce que je gagne en restant chez moi
n'est pas très importante bah ça c'est
important de l'entendre ce déplacement
dans les yvelines rentre dans le cadre
du tour de france engagée par le
président des républicains pour
recueillir les difficultés sur le
terrain et notamment dans ce bassin
industriel du nord du département un
territoire industriel qui subit de plein
fouet la concurrence internationale qui
se bat et qui veut rester un territoire
industriel et qui pour se faire à des
chefs d'entreprise des établissements
éducatifs comme celui là qui participe à
la compétitivité du territoire mission
reconstruction également dans la soirée
à versailles autour de la tête de liste
des républicains aux élections
européennes françois xavier bellamy au
début il ne faisait pas l'unanimité dans
son parti aujourd'hui les républicains
sont derrière lui bien sûr j'échange
avec gérard larcher j'ai eu l'occasion
de le voir de passer beaucoup de temps
avec lui il m'a redit à quel point
d'ailleurs il avait confiance dans le
fait que je pouvais apporter quelque
chose à cette liste il croyait que je
n'avais peut-être pas le poids politique
suffisant pour pouvoir être en tête de
liste et après tout c'est vrai que c'est
un pari et je suis prêt maintenant à
remporter ce défi
au delà du trio composé de françois
xavier bellamy d'agnès effréné d'arnaud
danjean
les républicains veulent porter une
certaine vision de l'europe
il faut absolument redonner sens à
l'europe parce que nous avons besoin
d'europe dans la mondialisation
mais nous avons besoin d'une europe
efficace d'une europe qui puisse agir
concrètement au service de nos
concitoyens
on est pour une europe de projets une
europe de coopération entre les pays
la reconstruction passe par les
élections européennes le 26 mai prochain
un résultat pour confirmer la victoire
des républicains aux yvelinois lors des
sénatoriales en septembre 2017
avec cinq sièges sur six remportée